RAMSEY HADDAD: Hello, everyone.
I hope you're doing
well and enjoying NEXT.
Just making sure you are
all in the right room.
This is CST 300.
We're going to talk about
project creation using
Terraform and cost controls.
Cool.
For the introduction, my
name is Ramsey Haddad.
I'm an Infrastructure
Cloud Consultant
with our Google Cloud
professional services practice,
based right here out
of San Francisco.
Our professional
services team works
with some of our
largest customers
to help them migrate their
workloads and applications
to GCP.
I've had the privilege
of working with CoreLogic
for the past eight
to nine months
and helping them
move their services
and applications over to GCP.
I'm actually joined here with
Jim Wolcott from CoreLogic.
JIM WOLCOTT: Thank you, Ramsey.
Thank you, everyone, for coming
and attending our session.
My name is Jim Wolcott.
I'm a Principal of Cloud
Solutions at CoreLogic.
And my job is to define how
we operate in the cloud.
We're going to have a chance to
touch on automation and labels
as part of that today.
Ramsey?
RAMSEY HADDAD: Just
an overview of how
we'll spend the next 40
minutes or so together.
I'll set the context of the
typical enterprise use case.
I'll give you some background
as far as what Terraform is.
And then I'll hand
it over to Jim
to talk about the CoreLogic
Cloud operating model.
And then we'll
actually flip over
to a demo of the null
label module in Terraform.
We'll wrap up and
then leave some time
at the end for Q&A for you
folks to ask questions.
I'm sure you must be familiar
with the Google Cloud Next app,
but you can actually
head on over there.
Tap this session.
And as you have questions
during our presentation,
you can feel free to hit
the Dory with any of those,
and we'll make sure
to get to those,
as well as live questions from
the audience towards the end.
So how many folks do we have
in the room that currently
are in the enterprise space?
All right, cool.
How many a solo
developer, startup folks
do we have in the room?
OK.
Can't really add those up, but
there's more enterprise folks
here.
There's a lot of
takeaways here that we'll
talk about that really touch the
cornerstone of enterprise use
cases but also can be applied
across different segments
of cloud consumption.
So what do most of our
enterprise customers
want as they move to the cloud?
Traditionally, a lot
of the conversations
that we're having with
customers a few years ago
were around data center
consolidation and cost savings.
That conversation has
shifted somewhat from,
why should I move to the cloud?
Is it safe to move to the cloud?
To how can I move to the
cloud as fast as possible
and how can you help me?
The idea here is we want
to introduce quick wins,
so that we can actually
pull away lessons and start
to actually change our behavior
earlier on in the process.
This allows us to actually
drive digital innovation,
and we can actually
maximize our velocity
to then move to the cloud.
So we want to move really quick.
We want to be able to not repeat
bad behaviors in the cloud.
But by doing that, we
need to do that in a very
secure and compliant way.
So repeatability control
is something we definitely
see from our customers.
All of our customers
want to be able to move
in a secure and compliant
way and build somewhat
of an abstract
approach to how they
work across multiple
environments in the cloud.
By abstract, we mean
deploying services
across multiple cloud platforms
in a very predictable way.
This lends developers to focus
on higher level types of work.
And then we can actually
reduce the blast radius
for when things go wrong.
So sometimes things
happen to go wrong,
and we want to be
able to minimize that
as much as possible with
having the right guardrails
and controls in place on your
foundations and infrastructure.
So I touched on this
in the beginning.
So cost savings is
very much a key driver
to move to the cloud.
But it's somewhat become
part of your point of entry
to move to the public cloud.
So at this point, we're
seeing our customers
really wanting to get
deeper understanding
of their operations to
understand what their behaviors
and functions are in the
cloud so they can build
high fidelity data models
to track that and change
those behaviors.
So the idea is that
we can actually
start to realize
deeper cost savings
and then start to improve and
mature our infrastructure so
that we can save more money.
So how do we get there?
What are the typical things that
we see in the enterprise space
where we can get to a place
where we are fully automated,
we have infrastructures,
code pipeline,
and we're starting
to actually take
those key aspects of
our usage of the cloud
and then change our behavior
to get more cost savings?
As simple as it
sounds, it starts
with actually defining
a set of best practices
that your organization
sees the best fit for you.
The idea here is to
actually take key aspects,
such as how you authenticate to
the cloud, your identity access
management, your security
posture, your networking,
your logging and monitoring,
as well as your billing
foundations.
Our professional services
team works really closely
with customers in the enterprise
space to help them step
through getting started
with their best practices.
The idea here is to
actually include billing
as part of your foundation
scope so that you
have the folks in the
room early on that
are making key decisions
that are ultimately
responsible for your
spend in the cloud.
The idea here is to actually
go through a workshop
to understand what your labeling
schema should look like,
make sure that
procurement folks that
are building the chargeback
for the public cloud
have a say as far as what
the key and value pairs are
that you're actually
putting on top of your cloud
infrastructure.
Then we move into actually
defining your GCP resource
hierarchy.
This is another
aspect of getting
to a place where you
can start understanding
your consumption in the cloud.
Your GCP resource hierarchy is
essentially your organization
onto GCP.
And there's three key
components there--
organizations,
folders, and projects.
And what this allows you to do
is group all your GCP resources
in a way that you can query,
filter, and then change
your behavior against that.
The idea here is that when we
work with a lot of customers,
we'd go through an exercise
to understand how we actually
break that folder structure out.
A lot of our customers
will break out their folder
structure based on
some development cycle,
whether that be a
QA, dev, production,
a common shared folders project.
And the idea is that we can
then take this folder structure
and then build a common
project deployment
framework against that folder.
There's actually a session
later today at 2:10
PM called CST200 that'll
actually step you through some
of the best practices
and how you actually
get started with getting set
up with your GCP resource
hierarchy.
We want to be able to focus
on repeatable patterns.
So we want to understand
what users and operators are
going to do most in the cloud.
I'll talk about
this in a bit here,
but project creation
is an excellent example
of how you can actually start to
introduce a repeatable pattern
and then build a lot of the
best practices into that.
So we can start building
reusable declarative
templates that allow us to scale
that foundation deployment.
Selecting a tool-- so Google
wants you, as a customer,
to select the right tool that
works for your organization.
There's a few key
considerations there.
One is around the
training and skill sets
available within your org.
So we encourage
you to really align
the vision and direction you
want to take your developers'
skills.
There's a few options there.
One is a native Google solution
called Deployment Manager
that's fully API supportable.
With Google's commitment
to open source,
there's also another tool
called Terraform, which
I'll talk about here shortly.
That also allows you to
build your infrastructure
as code pipeline and take
some of these common patterns
and deploy them widely.
Now, we have our best practices.
We know our GCP
resource hierarchy.
We have an understanding
of the foundations
and common patterns.
We've selected a tool.
Now we want to get into a place
we have extreme automation.
So the idea of this
is to basically codify
all of our best
practices in a way that
allows us to scale them and
remove any single person that's
doing manual deployments
across the environment.
We want to be able to take
elements of projects, networks,
identity access
management, and security,
codify them, and then also
treat them just as dynamic
as our application code.
Terraform-- so just going to
give a quick background as far
as what Terraform
is in this context.
So Terraform is an open source
infrastructure as code tool
by HashiCorp.
Terraform has this
concept of providers.
So it allows you to interact
with various public cloud
sources, such as GCP, AWS, and
Azure, as well as higher level
infrastructure services,
like Kubernetes.
Terraform declaratively defines
in a set of configuration files
what you want your
infrastructure to look like.
It'll give you a topology
that you can evolve over time
and build a workflow around
manning that infrastructure.
Terraform works
in three key ways.
There's a refresh, a
plan, and an apply.
And essentially that refresh is
your infrastructure described.
The plan is that real world
described in the infrastructure
in a configuration file.
And apply-- which
actually builds
that infrastructure for you.
So we take those three
elements, and then we
build a module in Terraform.
And a module is somewhat of a
black box of infrastructure,
where you can declaratively
define the variables and input
and control the
behavior of that module.
This allows us to
kind of encapsulate
a lot of complexity
around managing
traditional infrastructure.
We can take those modules
and then publish them
to a centralized repository.
So we'll talk about how we've
structured that in CoreLogic.
But ultimately, Terraform is
an excellent open source tool.
I mentioned there's
a provider for GCP.
So there's thousands of
contributors publishing best
practices for Terraform on GCP.
Now, coming to the
project factory--
I'm sure many of you are
aware of the concept of what
a project is, but a GCP project
provides a trust boundary
and resource isolation for
all of your GCP resources.
It's a basic resource
container for policies,
and infrastructure, and GCP.
So we want to be able to take
a lot of our best practices--
and because the project creation
is such an important part
of how you control your
environment in GCP--
we want to be able to take all
those best practices and harden
them into the creation process.
This allows us to stamp out
projects in a very consistent,
compliant way.
As you see here,
there's a number
of things that happen
in this project factory.
Everything from defining a
project in a standard naming
convention, to attaching
it to a shared network,
deleting all the
default configurations.
It allows us to
actually go through
and associate G Suite
accounts to that project.
But coming down a bit, it
allows us to actually maintain
a consistent framework for
how we associate projects
to billing functions.
Associating projects
to billing accounts--
something we definitely
see in the field
is that an inconsistent
project build process really
prevents us from making sure
that we associate projects
to billing accounts
in an accurate way.
So we can accurately
describe what labels
and what billing counts
we want to have associated
when the project gets created.
Setting up usage exports--
this is just kind of
another function here.
We want to be able to
enable as much metadata
about our usage in GCP.
So we suggest enabling
the GCE usage report
and dumping that into
a central GCS bucket.
Coming into applying billing
labels-- so one of the workshop
items I mentioned
earlier on defining
best practices is
really around kind
of building that label schema.
And what we want to do is
actually take the set of labels
and figure out which
ones are mandatory
and which ones are
optional, and make sure
that we incorporate that
as part of the foundation
build process for projects.
With that, I'm actually
going to hand it over to Jim
to talk about CoreLogic.
And then we'll go from there.
JIM WOLCOTT: Thank you, Ramsey.
OK, so a little bit
about CoreLogic.
CoreLogic helps you to find,
acquire, and protect your home.
Some of the services
that we have in CoreLogic
are like we provide listing
services to real estate agents
and brokers, we provide
valuation information
to lenders, and we
provide risk information
to insurance companies.
We're a global company.
And we're on a
three-year mission
to migrate all of our
applications and products
to the Google Cloud Platform.
So we've been working with
a professional services
organization in that endeavor.
And they've been fantastic,
especially as we've
been pushing the
envelope in some areas
and engage with their
engineering teams and product
managers.
Ramsey asked me to post
a couple of bullets
about why we chose the
Google Cloud Platform.
And CoreLogic, at its
heart, is a data company.
We have an enormous
amount of property data
in detail, which
we leverage in all
of our products and services.
The Google technologies are
very synergistic with this.
And so it's a perfect match for
CoreLogic from that standpoint.
The other thing is the
Google Cloud Platform
is really easy to automate.
And I know there's
a number of CSPs
out there that you can
apply automation to.
But in this case,
we're going to talk
about the entire environment
from the organization down
and how easy it is to
automate the entire thing.
So what problem are
we trying to solve?
How many people here
are motivated to go
to the cloud for the sake of the
agility that the cloud offers?
I assume most everyone, right?
And how many want to
achieve cost savings?
Well, we want them
both, don't we?
Right?
And that's the problem
we're trying to solve
is to drive the highest
value out of Cloud computing.
But it's challenging
in that most of us
are coming from a
static environment
and going to a dynamic one.
And while that
dynamic environment
gives us the agility
we're seeking,
it also raises new concerns.
Things like security, how do you
support fast-paced environment
like that, and also how
do you apply cost controls
into that environment?
So what is the solution to that?
We have to balance
all those things--
the need for the
controls, but also
to enable our cloud
development teams
to do what they are there to
do, which is to create products,
and innovate, and be agile.
So what we did is we
gathered around and came up
with some best practices or
principles around which we
apply to everything
that we're doing.
First of which is automate
everything, everything
that we possibly can.
But in that automation,
we also build in security,
both in the foundation,
on the IaaS side,
also in our pipelines.
So we pursue the goal of
shifting left in our pipeline
management to try
and test everything
up in the build area, including
vulnerability testing.
We also embrace
agility and change.
We're moving from
an environment where
we have a manual cab approval
mechanism to one where we
want to have much more change--
smaller changes but
many more changes.
So we need to have the
automation in there
as well and a way to track
the evidence of those changes.
We also have a philosophy
in this best practice
around, you build
it, you own it.
And what's great about
that is, as we transform
and our application teams gather
around that goal and that best
practice, it gives
us the ability
to be able to federate
out the support.
So we birthright
monitoring, and logging,
and we're able to
actually send the alerts
straight back to the
application development team.
They're able to resolve
incidents more quickly,
increasing the availability
of the products and services
that we have.
So how do these best
practices manifest themselves
in our CoreLogic
GCP environment?
We started in July of last year.
And we set out with
the first goal,
to automate the environment
from the organization down.
We produced a factory
for the network,
which is a global network.
Produced a factory for our
identity and access management
permissions and privileges.
We produced a factory for
managing firewall rules.
And then we produced
the cornerstone
of the entire environment,
which is the project factory.
Now, the project
factory, which we're
going to show some
code around that,
has some input
points that we have
to deliver in to create it.
But the project factory
is the cornerstone.
It provides a landing
zone that's hardened.
That has a number
of features that we
want to layer in for every
application team that's
migrating up to GCP.
So if you think about
this, we started in July.
We automated this organization.
We now have 600 projects
in the environment.
It took us a couple of months to
get invest in that automation,
right?
But now we can change labels
and we can change configurations
on projects across the entire
environment in five minutes.
It's fantastic.
It's the only way
we can really scale.
Now, this next slide you've seen
before, but it is so important,
and I wanted to
bring it up again.
It is a process.
And it's important
to really nail down
this process for the
very sake of the outcomes
that Ramsay indicated--
speeding up your migration,
having repeatability.
Having that cornerstone
of that project
built in the
organization gives you
consistency across the
entire environment.
So we do things like create the
project, attach it to the VPC.
These are all service
projects, by the way.
We delete all the defaults.
We set up the identity and
access management security.
The next bullet is
really important.
You have to assign that project
to the correct billing account,
right?
And then also set up
the usage data that
corresponds to that project.
And then we enable APIs
and we set our labels.
So that's the project factory.
Let's pivot to asset management.
So we've always been
taught asset management is
the number one thing we've
got to do in IT, right?
So how does asset management
translate up into the cloud?
It's a little bit different.
You don't have this
static infrastructure.
You have Cloud Services.
You have ephemeral machines.
How is it that you gain
the insights into what
you have in that environment?
Asset management's about
identifying, organizing,
and allocating, and then
being able to take action
on those assets.
So what do we do?
We wanted to define our
use cases in the cloud
and around assets.
So we came up with financial
use cases and operational use
cases.
And we defined those labels.
And then we assign those
labels to the project
at the project level
and resources as we
deploy resources.
Because that's all tied
to billing and usage data.
It's the billing
and usage data that
gives us the accuracy,
the precision of what's
sitting in that cloud
environment down to the second.
What else can do that?
So that's what we do.
We set all this up.
And then when the
project gets built,
we have that default
set of labels set up.
So if a workload owner is
moving up into the cloud,
there's already preset
labels there while they're
working in sandbox
getting their automation,
their pipeline set up,
so they can actually
apply labels onto the
resources they're using
and get down to a
more granular level.
We have it at the project level.
So we, in the labeling strategy,
produce these labels but.
There's a few
requirements that everyone
needs to be aware of
when going to the GCP.
First of all, all labels
need to be lower case.
They also can't have
special characters.
So some of our use
cases require notifying
the owners of those assets.
We can't use special characters
like email addresses.
So you have to have a
solution that allows for that.
We actually strip out
those special characters
and spell it out.
And we're able to then translate
that back to the right email
address.
The other thing
to note is, as you
are reporting on the
information coming out of GCP,
is that BigQuery has all
the columns for the labels
that you create.
But services are running at a
different pace from each other
and how they're populating
the data into those columns.
So as some services mature,
they have more information
being placed out into BigQuery.
So you just need to
watch for that as you
get into the reporting side.
Our top 10 labels here--
as I said, financial use cases,
and operational use cases.
We actually have two sets
of company and cost codes,
because on one hand, we want to
track the aggregate coming in
from GCP from a billing
perspective, the discounts,
and all that.
But then the other hand, we
want to be able to allocate out
to the workload owners.
In the environment, we want to
track our migration workloads
so we have an application
ecosystem label.
We also track the environment,
sandbox, non prod, prod,
the tier.
There's web, app, data tier.
Who the financial owner
is of those assets.
Who the tech lead is.
And then last but
not least is who
is going to fix the
problems that come up
when they are going to be
alerted from the monitoring,
right?
The resolver group.
So I wanted to do
a little demo here.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to talk about how to
create the common variables.
We're going to go into
a null label module.
And we're going then show the
project factory module as well.
And Ramsey's going to help out
and take us to the source code.
It does exist.
So what you see here, you
see a number of modules.
We have, as I was describing,
a firewall module.
We have the iam module,
the nat, network.
But the one we
want to begin with
is the terraform
null label module.
If you open that up, the first
thing that one needs to do
is declare their variables
in the variable.tf file.
How many people here are
really familiar with Terraform?
Oh, beautiful.
Right.
So I'm telling you probably
something you already know.
But you have to declare
your variables here.
And as you can see, we
have our mandatory labels
defined with the data types.
Quite simple.
Now, as we go into the main
file, just a couple of things
I'm going to show.
First thing, we do
have a reference
here to our confluence page
so that anybody building out
a null label file can
reference our standards,
our operating standards.
And then we have a
little bit of work
here to do to make sure we
conform to GCP requirements.
So we set a couple
regex expressions here
to help clean up any
values that are coming
in to the project factory.
And we use the kebab case
to transform any capital
letters to lowercase
and also to change
any underscores to hyphens.
And since you have a lot of
Terraform developers here,
you know what the kebab case is.
If not, it is a real thing,
just like the snake case,
and the camel case.
Well, we use it here.
And the whole point
is that we can
compartmentalize these variables
into a separate module.
We can have some of this
pre processing like this.
We can clean up the
values so that we
conform to GCP requirements.
Now we also reference, in
these kebab case statements,
every one of the
mandatory labels, right?
And once we're
done with that, we
can go to the project
factory module.
And here's the thing to note.
The very first thing is
that we want to reference
that null label module.
Right?
And then reference
the variables that
are going to be used
in this main tf file.
So we have here
reference all 10 of
the CoreLogic mandatory labels.
And then as we
scroll down, we also
have information on
the project creation
that needs to be populated--
the project ID, the organization
ID, the folder ID.
And it's vital that you
add the billing account.
And then we also have the
network that we attached to.
And then we reference
the label module
again here so that
when you run the apply,
it's going to pull labels
from the right place, right?
OK.
So our engineers created
this and they set up
a little example for us where
we just hard code the values
into the label variables.
And you can see here the hard
coded values going into the 10
labels that we have.
Now, this is in the main tf file
that would be in the project
factory module.
But we don't do it this way.
We use the .tfvar file
as part of our pipeline.
So we can add a form
in front and automate
the entire process.
And we do that for every
one of our modules.
So takeaways from this is
modularize your Terraform code.
Leverage the modules to be
able to separate your variables
and variable processing
from your main code.
And set up a proper
structure that can scale.
OK.
So now you can run your plan.
And then run your apply.
And with that, then
Ramsay, I think
we would go to the
GUI in the GCP Console
to take a look at that.
RAMSEY HADDAD: That's good.
Yeah, we can flip over
to the slides, please.
JIM WOLCOTT: So everyone's
familiar with the GCP Console.
You look under the iam in the
admin section, and of course,
go to labels and see
the key value pairs.
Just that simple.
A couple of sample reports we
just put together out of this.
Number one, we want to look at
the aggregate by cost center.
And we have a lot
of projects that
might group up under one primary
cost center or a chargeback
cost center.
So you'll see how those
cost centers are trending.
Second is in your
migrations, you're
going to want to track
your work packages.
And so having that
ecosystem ID to be
able to identify the
package is really
helpful in a number of ways.
You can see how that package
is moving into your sandbox,
into your non prod
environments, and into prod.
Also can see the effect
of any of your packages
on the shared services
projects, such as network
or your security projects.
And you start getting
insights into what is
happening in your migrations.
Great.
And so with that, thank you.
I'll hand it back to Ramsey.
RAMSEY HADDAD: Thanks, Jim.
So I wanted just to summarize
some of the key takeaways
from this session.
I know we went over
this relatively quickly.
But it's really important that
you set these best practices
up early.
As you kind of saw Jim
describe, CoreLogic
had these set of
10 required labels.
And the exercises that
we actually stepped them
through early on was actually
to go through and build
that naming convention,
build that key and value pair
combination.
That was not only relevant
to the business owners,
but that also made it really
easy for the developers
to interpret and incorporate
that into their pipeline.
Automating your project build--
so this notion of project
factory is an excellent place to
actually put a lot of your best
practices in control.
So really look to
the project creation
to ingest a lot of those
best practices as possible.
Using billing labels-- so one of
the things that we commonly see
is that either the labels
aren't being attached
in an appropriate way or they're
inconsistent and actually
aren't structured in
a uniform way that
makes sense to the business.
So we want to encourage
you to use billing labels.
But also make sure that you
incorporate those labels
into your infrastructure
as code pipeline.
So take all of these
costs governance,
your billing approach, your
billing account association.
And then take that
and then really start
to apply labels against that.
And then make sure that you have
that incorporated in your CSE
pipeline.
A few resources
to leave you with.
So there's a project internal
to Google called the Cloud
Foundation Toolkit,
where a group of Googlers
have actually come together and
built a standard set of modules
in both Terraform and
Deployment Manager.
For things to solve such
as project creation,
associating labels, all
the way up the stack
into things such as container
deployments and cloud storage,
as well.
Some resources if you're
interested in leveraging
these modules.
You can actually head over to
github.com/terraform google
modules.
And there's an active
community, as I
mentioned, through the
Terraform provider for GCP.
There's also an active community
within Google building up
those modules that fit
enterprise use cases.
So we want to make sure that
in all the read mes and content
that we have, you're able to
consume that and figure out
how to scale that
across your deployments.
Great.
And so given this on the
cost management track,
I wanted to point you to
a few other sessions that
fit into this space.
So there's 12 sessions
across cost management.
You can actually meet
the billing product team
at the infrastructure zone
on the showroom floor.
And if you would like to
actually see this session
and other ones alike,
you can actually visit
cloud.google.com/cost-management
for this video and others.